Welcome to the afternoon
of today's day of data.
We're actually-- we've made
up some remarkable time
over lunch.
Sorry to cut it a
little bit short,
but we do want to get to
these great presentations
this afternoon.
We're going to kick
off the afternoon
with the second keynote.
We have Erin
McKiernan, a professor
of physics, biomedical
physics, and neurophysiology
and an advocate for open access,
open data, and open science.
She is the founder of
Why Open Research?,
whyopenresearch.org,
an educational site
for researchers about
sharing their work.
She also blogs at
emckiernan.wordpress.com.
You can also follow
her on @EMcKiernan13,
and if you do get a chance to
talk to Erin about The Dead
Salmon, I encourage
you to do so.
She has a fantastic
way of summarizing
this great scientific story.
Thanks so much.
[APPLAUSE]
[AUDIO OUT]
Is it?
Is that working?
All right, great.
So I promised myself I
would put a timer on here.
I have that tricky
after lunch spot
where people are happy
because they've eaten
but also a little bit tired.
And so I'll try
to keep it lively.
So what I want to do today is
sort of step back a little.
We've been talking a
lot about open data,
but I think we tend to kind
of focus on that upper level
and say, oh, there's all
these great things we
can do with open data.
But when you're an
active researcher
and you actually decide
to do this yourself,
there's that moment
of panic where
you say, where do I start?
I don't know how to
actually do this.
So yes, I'd love
to share my data,
but what are the steps involved
in actually doing that?
So I'm going to back
up a little bit,
talk about what do
we mean by open data,
and walk you through a little
bit of my own experience
in sharing my data personally.
So just to start off.
So this-- the presentation
is openly licensed,
so feel free to
take photos, tweet,
do whatever you like with it.
After the talk, I'll
post it on figshare
so you can have those slides
to reuse however you'd like.
So I just wanted to
start off with kind
of a description of what
we mean by open science.
So open data is really
just one small part
of this bigger picture that is
open research and open science.
So as researchers,
we're producing
all kinds of different outputs.
We're producing articles,
but those articles
are just the very
tiny end product
of a much bigger process,
this research lifecycle
that Brian was talking about.
So when we talk
about open science,
yes, we have open
data, but we also
have open notebooks, which
I'll talk a little bit
about, open source,
so sharing your code,
and all kinds of other
aspects, open peer review,
open educational resources.
With the idea that as
educators and as researchers,
we should be sharing all
these products that we're
producing along the way.
So I'm only going to focus on
open data and open notebooks
and open source
today, but just wanted
to give you the idea that it's
a much bigger space than just
what we're seeing today.
So the Foster Group
has actually worked
out what they call an
open science taxonomy,
which I think is fantastic.
And so you can see some
of the main categories
they have here, open access,
open data, open science
evaluation, policies, tools.
And we're really
just going to focus
on the ones I have circled here.
So what do we mean by open data?
What are the
international standards
for that, for data
use and reuse?
Open lab notebooks, which
is a relatively new thing,
but I think an emerging
area of open science.
And then some of the work
flow and repository tools
that we can use
to share our work.
So why open data?
I think most of us here are
convinced that open data is
a good thing, but there are
many different perspectives
we can take as to why
that's a good thing.
So one is the
researcher perspective,
why would I want to do this
from a selfish perspective?
Well, there are a few studies,
mainly from Heather Piwowar,
which show that if you
share your data associated
with a study, that study
then gets more citations.
So this is more visibility
for the researcher
and a personal benefit for them.
So I think it's important for
us as advocates to consider
that researchers, especially
in the early stages
of their career,
are understandably
interested with their
career advancement.
We don't want anybody to
sacrifice their career
for the sake of
the movement, and I
don't think that's necessary.
There are lots of different ways
that they can share their work
and be successful,
and in some cases,
get an edge up, get
increased visibility.
So that's one of
the reasons why we'd
like to see researchers
share, for their own benefit.
Another one, so reproducibility.
So I think that this
image captures nicely what
we like to think about in
terms of reproducibility.
This is from the Wide
Open Research Project,
so these cartoons are by my dad.
I teamed up with
him through-- yeah,
it's an awesome thing to be
able to team up with a family
member on this project.
So we teamed up,
and the idea was
to create very visual ways of
transmitting to researchers
the importance of
reproducibility,
the importance of open
science, and some of the ways
that they could benefit
from sharing their own work.
So on the web
page, which I think
you actually can't get into with
the current Wi-Fi connection.
I couldn't access.
But we do have an image
gallery, and all those images
are openly licensed.
So you can reuse those
however you'd like.
So we talked a lot today
about the importance
of reproducibility.
One of the tenants
of science is we'd
like to see that not
just this lab can produce
this particular result. But
when I take those methods
and I try to do
it in my own lab,
that I can get the
same or similar result,
thereby confirming
their findings.
And so how can you do this
if you can't figure out
what they've done?
So if you can't
understand the protocol,
if you can't understand
what the data looks like,
how can you go about
reproducing that study?
The short answer
is that you can't.
So we need open data
for reproducibility.
So this has been talked
about a few times.
I think, Brian, you're
in part of this cartoon.
So this is a great
cartoon series
that [INAUDIBLE] did
on reproducibility,
the replication crisis.
And so we would like to see that
when we read through a paper,
we check the methods, and we
try to do that in our own lab
that we get a similar
or the same result.
But what's happening in a lot
of these large-scale replication
efforts is we're seeing
that a very small percentage
of those studies can
actually be reproduced.
And I think a lot of us have
personal experience with this.
As graduate students,
you enter a lab,
and they say, look, very easy.
In a couple of weeks you
just reproduce this result,
and everything will be fine.
And then you start with
the rest of your project.
But then you spend
a year or two years
or however long trying
to reproduce that result
and sometimes getting
completely different results.
And it's very frustrating,
and it wastes a lot
of time and effort and money.
So what we'd like to see is
an acceleration of science
through data sharing.
So this is an example
of a study that we're
trying to validate of 50
high-profile cancer studies,
and what they found was
tremendous difficulty
in getting access to
the original study data.
So trying to find
out what they'd done,
what the data looked like,
so that they could then
go and reproduce these studies.
And there are many times where
you contact those authors,
and they just don't respond.
And so this is slowing
down the pace of science.
Another thing, so I
really appreciated--
[INAUDIBLE], so you were talking
about the impact, the larger
impact beyond just
academia, what
is the impact of sharing data?
So this is a new project called
the Open Data Impact Map,
and what they're doing is
trying to gather together
case studies, again,
all over the world,
about particular companies,
some social justice
projects that are reusing data.
In a lot of these cases,
it's open government data,
but in some cases, it might
be, as well, research data.
And they're raising
that data, but not
in an academic environment,
now in a social justice
or civil or public health
problems type of environment.
So I just pulled out
a couple of examples
from Mexico that I
think are interesting.
So this is CREA, which
is a project that
tries to empower
and encourage women
to start their own businesses
and to be independent.
And this is
particularly for women
in socially and economically
disadvantaged areas.
So this is a fantastic project,
and they're using open data
as part of this project.
Another example.
This project is looking at what
types of oil and gas mineral
extraction is going on in
different areas in Mexico.
Is that invading on or
damaging indigenous lands?
How is that affecting
the environment?
And so they're using open
data, and I think even
in some cases producing
their own open data
to defend these
lands and to promote
human rights and environmental
conservation in these areas.
So fantastic uses of open
data and just another reason
why we should be caring
about this issue.
So but then as a researcher,
you run into this problem,
like I said.
You say, OK, so all
this sounds great to me.
I'm convinced.
So how do I actually
do this, right?
And so I want to
emphasize this point.
Dumping a spreadsheet
online is not open data.
This is not what we
mean by open data,
right, because dumping that
spreadsheet online doesn't
necessarily mean anybody else
can understand those data
or reuse them in any way.
So how do we share our data
in a way that's understandable
and hopefully usable by others?
Because that's what
we'd like to see.
So I think the first
step for me, especially,
was to understand what are
the international standards.
What do we mean by open data?
If we don't mean it's just
dumping a spreadsheet,
what do we mean?
So this is the open definition
from the Open Knowledge
Foundation, and they say that
"open data and content can
be freely used,
modified, and shared
by anyone for any purpose."
So that's their definition.
It sounds broad,
but I think it's
important to emphasize this
issue of modify and reuse.
So if I dump a
spreadsheet out there
that nobody else can understand,
nobody's going to modify that.
Nobody's going to reuse that.
That's not open data.
So this is one of the
international standards
with respect to open data.
Another one is the
Panton Principles,
and I like this because the
name comes from the fact
that the first draft was put
together at the pub called
Panton Arms in Cambridge.
And so this is the group
that worked on that.
So they just have
sound very basic
but, I think, important
recommendations to state.
So the first is that if you're
going to share your data,
you should share it along with
an explicit statement on how
you want those data
to be reused or what
reuse you want to limit.
That you should use
a recognized waiver,
a legal type of
waiver or license
that specifies the rights, the
reuse rights on those data,
particularly that you
should make data truly open.
And that, what we mean
here is that there
are no restrictive clauses.
So it's very common
to see data or even
articles released under
a Creative Commons
license that has a no
commercial restriction.
And people, at least
intuitively, think, well yes.
I'd like to limit
commercial entities
coming in, packaging up my
materials, and reselling it.
But what it does that is not an
intended restriction, I think,
is that there are
some cases where
educational institutions
and even nonprofits
can be considered
commercial entities.
And then that restricts
their reuse of the data.
So we don't want
to start putting
those types of restrictions.
If possible we want to place
data in the public domain
so people can reuse
it, remix it however
they like without
worrying about tracking
the attributions or any
commercial restrictions there.
And by the way, as
a point of action,
you can sign on to
these Panton Principles
and say that you
agree with these.
So step 2.
You know the definition
of open data.
You've decided you're
going to share your data.
You need to find a
trusted repository,
and you have a lot of choices.
This is another thing that's
overwhelming for researchers.
Where do I put these data?
So I've just put a
few options here.
Open Science Framework that
was discussed this morning.
GitHub is another common one,
more commonly for sharing code,
but you can also share data.
And you can have the data
and the code together,
which can be advantageous.
Data Dryad and Zenodo,
which is run by CERN.
Figshare is one
that I use a lot,
and the reason that I use it
is because it's very easy.
It's user friendly.
It's fast to upload things.
And this is another
important factor.
If we're talking to
researchers and we're
trying to convince
them to do something,
we want that low
barrier to entry.
We don't want to make their
work flow more complicated.
We want to make it easier.
I think this is something we
also saw with the Open Science
Framework.
We want to make things
easier and faster.
Instead of having to visit a
number of different platforms,
if you have that integration,
things go much smoother.
So all of these
platforms kind of
have their different features,
but they're all archiving.
They have some type of
preservation through locks.
You get, for most of these, some
type of permanent identifier
that you can go back to
or that people can site.
There are metrics,
you know, number
of forks of your repository,
how many people are
looking at it, how many people
are reusing and contributing
to it.
So any of these are good
solutions for sharing data.
Let's talk about formats.
So you've decided you're
going to share your data.
You picked your repository.
And then what are you going
to put in that repository?
Again, we're not going to
dump our spreadsheets, right?
And we're definitely not
going to put things in PDF.
So-- we'll talk about
that in a minute.
So not everyone-- it's important
to recognize not everyone
has a Microsoft license
at their institution.
These licenses are expensive.
And a lot of institutions in
the US and Canada and Europe
may be fortunate to
have those licenses,
but other institutions in
other parts of the world
don't have that.
So if you're releasing
your file formats
in those proprietary formats,
they can't access those data.
So it may be there, but it may
still be inaccessible to them.
So sharing in these
nonproprietary formats
allows everybody to open those
files and work with them.
So here we kind of have a chart.
You've got your, you've got
your proprietary file formats
over here, things like
Microsoft Word, Microsoft Excel,
and here you have kind
of the equivalent.
So instead of Excel, we
can publish those data
in CSV format, and
that's something
that most people should be
able to open even though they
don't have a Microsoft license.
And then we have, also, this
issue of machine readability.
So a PDF is not an
ideal format for data,
although many governments
are using this.
Mexico releases a lot of
its-- although it's great
that we release the
open government data,
a lot of that is in PDF format.
So if you want to
use it, you have
to copy each row
into a spreadsheet,
and it takes a long time.
And it's just not an efficient
way of sharing those data.
So thinking about
file formats is
something important in
terms of accessibility,
the data you're sharing.
So Tim Berners-Lee has developed
this great five-star rating
system for open data.
And so, as you can see,
PDF falls on the end,
the one-star end of this scale.
And so the idea is that,
well, it's not ideal,
but it's out there,
so you should
at least get one star for that.
OK, so you've shared it
in some type of format,
but it's not machine readable.
It might be in a
proprietary format,
and you can't really reuse
that or modify that, right?
This is part of that
open definition.
You can't modify it.
So going up to the next level.
Let's make it available
as structured data.
So two stars if you've got that
in some type of spreadsheet
format that now people at least
can modify, play with, assuming
they have the license to
open those Excel files.
Going up to the next
level, three stars.
So now you've got
openly licensed data.
You've got it machine readable.
And now you have it in a
nonproprietary file format
that people all over, even if
they don't have that Microsoft
license, can open,
modify, reuse.
And then you've got
these higher levels
that are related to adding URLs
and then linking your data set
to other data sets.
So these are the
most advanced levels.
My shared data,
I'm still at three.
I haven't gotten to
four or five stars yet,
but I think that's OK.
I'm happy with three
stars, for now.
But just to kind of
emphasize the point
that not all open
data is created equal.
So it depends how we're
sharing these data,
what format they're in, and
how we're connecting them
with other data
sets that determines
how reusable those data are.
So we like badges, here.
I think we're all agreed
that we like badges.
And so you can get these badges
and stick them on your data
sets and say, hey, this
is the level of compliance
I have based on this
five-star system.
And then people also know
what they can and can't
do with that data, right?
So again, OL meaning you have
an open license on there.
Machine readable, and
then an open format.
So my data is currently out
three stars out of five.
So what happens if you have
data, you've collected it,
and it's in a
proprietary format.
And you really don't have a good
way of sharing it or converting
it to another format?
So I ran into this--
we collect neural
recording data,
and a lot of the software that
allows you to take these to--
register these recordings
is proprietary.
And so you end up with files
that other people can't open,
and those licenses are
ridiculous expensive.
So what we did in
this case was--
someone was talking about
Stack Overflow at lunch.
So I want to give a big
shout out to Stack Overflow,
because the fantastic thing
about this open source
community is you can go on there
and say, I have this file type.
I need to figure out how to make
it readable to other people.
How do I do that?
And there's a community of
people who already figured out
how to do that and are willing
to share their solutions
with you.
So Stack Overflow can be
this amazing tool for you
to figure out how
to do these very--
what sound like simple
things but may not
be entirely trivial.
So I wrote this small,
little piece of code,
and a lot of it's copy-paste
from some of the solutions
that I found on Stack Overflow.
That's great.
And that allowed me to put that
code up with my data and say,
if you don't have this
particular software
to open the file,
you can open it
with this little piece of code.
And so that solved the
proprietary file format issue.
So even people who didn't have
that, they can now punch--
and it shows--
I show them how to run
this little piece of code
so they can open all the files.
And there's no issue there.
So there are
workarounds you can use,
and there are these
great communities that
are willing to help you figure
out how to do this stuff.
So step 4, create a master data
log file, or in other words,
show me the metadata.
So again, dumping a spreadsheet
online, not open data.
Because a lot of the time what
we have in those spreadsheets
are these abbreviations
that nobody else
but us can understand.
And so in my case, I
have-- there's one person
in the audience I know who
understands these abbreviations
but that's because we
worked in the same lab.
So there are these
abbreviations of genetic lines
that I'm using, and if I just
dump that out there, nobody
is going to understand what
that means or how to reuse it.
So I need to have some
information on that.
And then this file,
in particular,
has all the files that
I'm going to release
as part of the data set.
So it has here the date for
each recording, the channel
or the file number that
corresponds to that
file that I'm going
to share with you,
the particular
experimental condition.
In this case, it's a
genetic manipulation.
And then all the
data here, and I
have to explain to you, what
does "birth start A" mean?
Do you know, do you
know what that means?
No, you shouldn't
know what that means.
I should explain that to you.
So I think it's
important to emphasize
that your data are really not
as clear as you think they are.
You've been working with
these data for a long time.
You've been looking
at them every day.
They make sense to you,
but they don't make sense
to other people.
And so you have
to explain what's
there so that
people can reuse it.
So part of that is
creating what they
call a README file, a detailed
README file that explains
exactly what's in the data set.
So what is included?
Does this data set correspond
to a published article
or pre-print, because we
want a link up those outputs.
That's where we're
linking open access
to publications with open
data that corresponds
to that publication.
You have to explain
the overall data
structure, any
abbreviations or terminology
that you're using that might
be unusual, and explain
any missing data.
So in my data set,
for example, I
was recording a pattern of motor
activity in a little Drosophila
larva.
And what happens is
not every animal has
the same amount of
activity, so that
means if I'm recording
those bursts,
not every animal in that sample
has the same amount of data.
And so I need to
explain to people
why it is that this recording
has 10 bursts, and this has 30.
Or something like that.
Why are the files sets
not the same size?
So, this is just an example.
I put my README file
up here on GitHub.
And then I linked
it, and I said,
all the code and data
in this repository
correspond to the pre-print
that can be found here.
So I'm linking, now, my
publication with my data set.
So here's that publication.
This is a pre-print.
I never succeeded
in getting this
to go through official
journal review.
But that's OK, because
it's out there.
And in particular,
this was a null result.
So I did a genetic manipulation.
It didn't have an effect, or
at least a measurable effect.
And I think it's
important that people
know that I did that study
and didn't find anything,
because again, there might
be graduate students in labs
somewhere in the world
trying to do this again.
And they should know that
somebody has already tried it,
and it didn't work, right?
So I put this pre-print
up on PeerJ Preprints,
which is one of the pre-print--
one of the many
pre-print servers.
And I put a note on
that that now says,
all the data and analysis
code associated with the study
can be found in this
GitHub repository.
So on my repository in GitHub,
it's linked to my pre-print.
On my pre-print in PeerJ,
it's linked back to my data,
so that everything
is integrated.
And I think this will
stay a pre-print forever,
but that's OK.
I'm fine with that.
All right.
So you've done all that.
You've put your data there.
It's in nonproprietary
format, hopefully
you've got three stars.
You've got your
README file there.
And then what you need
to explain to people
is at least how you analyzed it.
So they may come up with
another way to analyze it,
but you should have
some explanation,
especially if you've
developed special code.
So with this project, I
developed a Python code
that was specific to
analyzing these type of data,
and so I should
explain to people
what I did with that code.
So one of the great tools that's
developed in the last few years
are these electronic notebooks.
So I-- they used to
be called IPython.
Now they're Jupyter Notebooks,
but it's the same idea.
So this is an open source,
very interactive platform
for sharing code and hopefully
sharing a detailed explanation
that walks people
through the code
and allows them to
understand exactly what it
does in each part.
So let me see if I can
show you an example here.
So what I first needed
to explain to people
was how to access the data,
how to open the files.
Sounds trivial, but it
wasn't in this case.
That's why I had that
little piece of code that
allowed them to open the file.
So I needed to
explain to them, OK.
So first of all, you
need to open the file.
Here's how you're
going to open it,
and here's how you're
going to plot it.
And so that's what
this explains.
So I put my little command here.
And that's an interactive
cell, and you just
press, you run the code
that's in the cell.
And then the output
comes out here below.
So here I've said, well, let's
read this particular file
that's in the data set.
I want to read it
within this time window.
And they can change
that time window
if they'd like to view a
different part of the data set.
And then when I run
that cell, here's
what it's going to
produce as an output.
And the nice thing is,
because it's interactive,
they can change it.
So they could change
this file number.
They can view a
different one, or they
can change the window of time.
If they want to zoom in
on one of these bursts,
it's not static in
other words, right?
So they can go and they can
interact with those data
however they'd like.
All right.
So they can open the
files, and now I'm
explaining to them
with a notebook how
I analyzed the data.
So telling them, run
this little piece of code
that I have, specify
the CSV files,
because we have a
nonproprietary file format.
So run these files.
And I'm explaining to them here
that you're running a control
file, and you're
comparing that to one
of the genetic manipulations.
And then I'm saying, OK.
You go through, you run
this, and then-- poof--
you get all your
data right here.
And they can-- again, they
can change the spreadsheet
that they want to look at.
They can change the data set.
So if they think,
for example, I might
have picked a very neat,
clean pretty data set,
then they can change
this and look and see
if the other sets
are that pretty.
Or if I'm presenting one
that's not representative.
So again, increasing
transparency by letting them
interact with the data and plot
whatever they'd like to plot.
So it spits out the data,
and then, of course,
you'd like them to be
able to visualize it.
So in this, I'm
explaining to them--
there's obviously more
explanation involved here--
but explaining to
them, OK, so here's
how we're going
to plot the data.
And here's how we're
going to compare the two
conditions, the control in black
and the genetic manipulation
in white.
We're going to overlay
those distributions
and see if there's any change
between the two conditions.
This is where you can
see it has no effect.
Those distributions were
almost completely overlapping.
But the great
thing here is these
are the same figures that
are included in my pre-print.
So if they'd like to
check exactly what I did,
exactly how I created those
figures, they can go back
and run the same
analyzes and see
if it spits out the same
figures that I claim
are the data in the pre-print.
So I think the
message here is really
that open data is
reproducible science.
Open science is
Got these little-- so this is
GitHub, right, the octocat.
I'm not sure how they
came up with that logo.
I'd love to know the
story behind that one.
And then Jupyter.
So by combining my
GitHub repo that
has all my code, all my
data, and all my explanation
files, my metadata,
my READMEs, I
can then have my science
be much more reproducible.
Because anybody can
go in, they can access
the raw and the process data.
All of that's there.
They can reproduce all the
analysis that in my pre-print
I said I did.
They can replot every
figure from the pre-print
and make sure that
those comparisons are
what I said they are.
And they can then reanalyze my
data using different methods.
So let's say they decide that
the way that I was analyzing it
wasn't necessarily the best way.
And they've developed
another way to do that,
or they've even written
a piece of code.
If I have it in GutHib,
they can fork my repository.
They can make their own copy.
They can write
another piece of code.
They can reanalyze the
data, and then they
can send me a request
to incorporate that
into my own project.
And that way I can have people
contributing and saying,
you know what?
I think you didn't quite
analyze it the right way.
Or hey, I analyzed
it a different way.
The results came out the same.
And people can then feed
back into this project,
contribute new tools
and an analysis.
So this is by Lorena Barba.
She has this great thing
called the Reproducibility PI
Manifesto, and it's
really these basic things
that she does, kind of
bringing this all together
to make sure that her lab is
producing reproducible science.
So first of all, they
have version control.
So all of their code is in a
repository where every time you
make a change, every
time you save a new file,
that change is recorded.
You can go back and look
at the whole history.
You can look at
who's contributing.
You don't have final, final,
not this one, that one, final,
so that type of
problem is avoided.
They do verification and
validation on all their code,
and then they publish
those validation reports,
which I think is fantastic.
They openly license
all their materials.
One of the tricks
she uses is, say
they have figures from-- bless
you-- figures from a study.
They post those on figshare
under an open license,
and then no matter where
they publish afterwards,
say they publish in a
subscription journal,
that Creative Commons
license is irrevocable.
And so those figures
are open, and anyone
can go back and reuse
them, regardless
of where the final
article gets published.
So all of that is
openly licensed.
They post pre-prints.
I just have the
example of arXiv here,
but again, we saw there's many
places where you can publish
that work prior to
official publication,
and you can even get
feedback during this process.
And I think there
are some people that
are very afraid of this.
Why on earth would I put myself
out there and post something
before it's really finished?
My perspective on this is
that I'd rather somebody
come to me in this
stage and say,
I found an error in your
paper, than come to me
when I have the published
version of record.
And now I have to go
and talk to the journal
and put an official
error statement
or something on that article.
I'd much rather that come
sooner rather than later.
Open code, so they
share all their code
openly under an open license.
And then they have
this web presence,
the idea being that they should
have a website where they're
sharing these materials and
where people can contact them
with feedback.
One of the most
important things she says
is she teaches all her students
to do science this way.
And the fantastic thing about
that is, hopefully, we're
creating this new
generation of scientists
that academically grow
up thinking this is just
the way we do things.
This is part of the
normal process of science.
And by the time they get
into the faculty positions,
this hopefully will
start to become the norm,
because they grew up that way.
Open notebooks, so this is
sort of a newer development.
So the idea being you're
not just sharing data,
but you're sharing
this whole process.
And you're doing
it in real time.
So all those
notebooks that you're
writing in the lab what you
did with that experiment
for that particular
day that used
to then sit there on a shelf
and gather layers of dust.
And once that grad
school left the lab--
that that grad student left lab,
they never got looked at again.
And hopefully, we can
open up that process,
make it more transparent,
and publish these somewhere.
So this is an open
source malaria project.
They've really been kind of
pioneers in this open notebook
space.
And the idea here
is that they share--
see I knew my timer would
stop and just fail me--
that they share all their
science in real time.
And they operate
under what they call
the six laws of open research.
So all data are open.
All ideas are shared.
Anyone can take part, so
kind of increasing the equity
that we'd like to see in
the scientific process.
No patents.
They are looking for drugs
that could potentially
cure or slow down malaria,
and they have committed
to not patenting any of that.
And I think that's amazing.
Suggestions being the
best form of criticism.
This one's great.
Public discussion is much more
valuable than private email.
And also that an open project
is bigger and not owned
by any particular lab.
So we have a goal here.
We'd like to help
people that are
in countries that are suffering
from high rates of malaria.
That has nothing to do
with my personal success
as a scientist.
That's a global
public health problem,
and that's where I should be
focusing my efforts, rather
on what's mine, mine, mine.
So after I went through this
whole process of sharing
my data, and I announced on
Twitter, look you want my code?
You want my data?
You can have it.
It's all here.
I got this tweet and it
said, "Aren't you worried
someone will find something
in your data that you missed,
and then they get the glory?"
And I think this is
a really common fear,
the fear of scooping
is something
that's preventing a
lot of researchers
from going and sharing
their material.
And I did not have the
perfect response to this.
Rik Smith-Unna did, and he
said, "If Erin missed it
and nobody else
ever saw the data,
the world missed
out on the knowledge
and nobody got the glory."
And I think that's a
perfect way of summarizing
the benefits here.
I had been looking at
those data for a long time.
If I hadn't seen it out by
then, I wasn't going to see it.
And just to kind of
further drive that home
and to close with two
of my favorite quotes.
So from Peter Murray-Rust
and the ContentMine,
"You cannot assume how others
will want to reuse your work."
There may be all these
things to do with those data
that you never, ever thought of.
And if you don't share those,
you'll never find that out.
And then by Rufus Pollock from
Open Knowledge, "The best thing
to do with your data will be
thought of by somebody else."
So with that, I'll close,
and open up to questions.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[INAUDIBLE]
Use my data?
Not Not very many, actually.
So the repository has a few
forks there from people,
mostly that I know.
One of them was my
brother, who decided
he wanted to improve my code.
[LAUGHTER]
So, he's a programmer.
So not many people
have used those data.
It's a very kind of
obscure data set.
So I was looking at a very
specific, tiny little mutation
in a Drosophila larva, and
how many people in the world
are really interested in that?
I don't know.
But I hope someday, somebody
will find it useful.
And for me, I think it was very
useful, just the whole process
of figuring out how to do that.
So that when, hopefully, I do
have a potentially more useful
data set, that process will
go a lot faster for me.
In what ways or how
does your choice
to follow these principles
limit your ability
to make use of commercial codes
that may offer capabilities
for analysis of data that
are very hard to reproduce
in open source applications?
So, yeah, so in my lab--
I mean everything we
do, everything we use
is open source.
Up until recently I was
running a Linux machine.
I've now converted to Mac.
But, so everything
we do is open source,
and I haven't run
into any limits.
The most serious one was
when I was figuring out
how to reopen--
how to open these
recordings that I had.
So that kind area of
software is very locked down
by proprietary programs,
but then, you know,
I went on to Stack Overflow.
I found this.
I solved the problem.
It didn't take that long.
I really haven't found that
it's been restrictive for us
as researchers.
Let me just follow up.
We have many chemists
at Yale, for instance,
who make use of our high
performance computing
facilities, and
they probably use
half a dozen
different codes that
do have an issue, quantum
chemistry, for instance.
And I think that they would
argue that each code is
unique in its
capabilities in some way,
and I suspect that they would
think that they would produce
less good science
were they restricted
to use just one or two
of them that may be
public domain or open source.
As opposed to having a suite
of things, some of which
may work better for what
they are particularly
focused on than others.
Is that-- so in general
terms, would that
be a problem for
this kind of thing?
Yeah, so I can't speak
specifically to those.
I don't know those,
but I can imagine cases
where that might be true.
Also, there's also the problem
of reinventing the wheel.
If you know that
this package already
exists and does what
you want, are you
really going to invest the
time to create an open source
version of that?
And who is going to compensate
you for that time investment?
I understand that
that's an issue.
So there may be moments where
it's more advantageous for you
to use, at least temporarily
use, the closed solution
that's there.
You know, these are
also my personal choices
as to the restrictions
that I put on the way
we do things in the lab, but
I don't mean by any sense
that everybody has
to do all or nothing.
There is this continuum
of open practices,
and I think it's very
important to recognize
that people should do
the level of sharing
that they're comfortable with.
Do you have any
advice for people
who have data that they
can't actually release?
They want to do as
much open as they can,
but maybe they have private
data that they're not
allowed to release.
Yeah, so I mean, there
will be data sets
that for privacy concerns
or for legal reasons,
you're not able to release.
And that's OK.
I would say the
first piece of advice
is to make sure that
that's actually the case.
So sometimes we tend to think
that we don't have the right
to share those data.
Data ownership is a
little bit tricky.
Or we think that maybe
anonymizing those data
might be impossible
when there might
be somebody else who's figured
out how to solve that problem.
So I would kind of reach
out to people in your field.
Maybe reach out to even legal
in your university and ask them
questions about whether--
how restricted you actually are.
And then, if you really
can't share the data,
that's understandable.
That happens sometimes,
but you can share
other parts of the process.
So you can share the instruments
or your analysis code or maybe
some metadata, depending
on whether there's
sensitive information there.
So sharing all the
things that are related
to that project that aren't
necessarily the data, I think,
is still a great step
in the right direction.
If we got all researchers
to do that, we'd be--
I don't know if
we'd be here today.
We'd be way better
off than we are today.
So yeah, I think,
again, we don't
want to tell people
it's all or nothing.
You share what you can.
And if there's stuff that
you can't or you're not yet
comfortable with sharing,
I think that's OK.
And I think we should support
people in those decisions.
Hi.
So regarding the malaria
project that you talked about,
so they kind of pledged
to do no patents,
but that doesn't start--
or stop the other companies
on getting patents, right?
So I mean, there is actually
a lot of debate in genomics--
I don't know if you're
aware regarding this stuff.
So I mean, do you
have any ideas on how
to do open science with this
threat of the companies--
well, I mean for example,
like, human genome is
kind of protected by, right
now, the judges, I guess.
So to speak, right?
They cannot really
patent human--
like parts of human genome, no.
Otherwise, we would
be like-- we wouldn't
be able to do any
good science, right?
So I mean what are
your thoughts on this,
like how to do science with--
Yeah, so I'll preface this by
saying that I'm not a lawyer,
so let's get that
disclaimer out of the way.
So in the case of the open
source malaria project,
they are posting their
progress on a daily basis.
They're publicly sharing
their entire process and all
the data, which means that,
as far as I understood,
that that would
count as prior art.
So if somebody else tried to
file a patent based on that,
they could very-- they have
all the date and time stamps.
They could very easily say, no.
We have already done a
public disclosure of this
that counts as prior art.
You cannot claim
a patent on that.
That's what I understand,
at least under US law.
Patent law varies a
lot internationally,
so there might be some
exceptions to that.
But there shouldn't
be the case that it
would be very easy for someone
to just come in and co-opt all
their material and patent that.
I do get a lot of questions
about whether commercialization
is necessarily mutually
exclusive with open science.
I don't think that's the case.
There are some great
models in open source--
so Mozilla being one-- that
they share all their code,
and they still manage to have
a successful business model.
There are companies
that do that.
So they release the code,
but what they commercialize
is their personal
one-on-one advice
about how to run the code
or troubleshoot or whatever.
And they still manage to
run successful companies,
commercializing that aspect
while making all the code free.
So I think there
are lots of ways,
creative ways that
companies can exist,
that research products can
be commercialized and still
be open.
Any more questions?
No?
All right.
Thank you very much.